I remember at the end of the first
season you said do you realize that
every at least one guest spot was hired
was fired every week at the after the
table read and the first season
and it was and I looked back and I go
he's right
somebody was fired and I won't say what
name some names I've been fired off the
table
um and it's and it's especially in that
world the sitcom world is it's so unless
you're hitting it at the table there's
no job security and you're proving it at
every run-through and you're fighting
for those jokes that every run through
and and it's it's a very much a
fear-based medium we've done a a bit of
a half hour too right four counts yeah
exactly you know my buddy John
uh I won't say his last name I don't
think he gives a [__]
but he did a table read for a Will
Ferrell who is Farrell's partner Adam
McKay at the time
they had this TV show
and he flew to wherever
and he did the table read and he went to
his room
and his agent called him and said hey
man they let you go he's like what
he's like yeah the table read I guess
didn't go well they're looking for
somebody different and he's like so he
had to get on a plane and fly back check
yeah
yeah what's happening to me do you get
how yeah how do you how do you remember
feeling oh awful just completely
rejection rejection oh listen I remember
it happened to me and then I I got off
the phone and my son was there and I was
like I just got fired and he's like and
he's amazing he's responsible you'll get
another one and he's like I was like
thank you for that that was so sweet of
him but it's it's one of those things
where you just go
you take the blow you take the hit and
you know obviously you you pick yourself
up and you know day at a time kind of
thing but you can't help but take it
personally there's a million reasons why
yeah there's there's wrong with me what
is it yeah am I not maybe I'm not that
great they found me out I'm not a great
actor yeah I'm the Imposter that I
always thought I was it's there's a
million reasons this is [__] it's
because of fear-based and they didn't
come and say hey
um let's talk to you about the role you
know the reading we would cast it for a
reason you could more energy whatever
they just fire you it's so stupid or
arbitrary or there's always been uh a
hang up about hiring in the first place
and they had someone else in mind and
they never got their way and there's so
there's all of these things that are
layered with these decisions yeah that
summer control some of them are out of
your control some are not but some are
out of your control you can't guess
which ones are which you know I hate
table reads
like they're awful they're awful because
you don't know if you're giving too much
energy they think I'm gonna be like this
on the show or and maybe I'm like this
I'm like oh no he's kind of boring [__]
you
and [__] yeah and and you write I know
you're right right you're right are you
you're right yeah yeah so you know do
you find that a table read is helpful to
you as a writer oh absolutely just to
read I've had some Pilots rad that I've
written and having friends come over and
read them and bring them to life
absolutely it brings life to them and I
also when I hear them out loud I go yeah
yeah that's not what I want in my head
interesting obviously but
um yeah I think it does help you as a
writer it helps you you know what you
have on the page sometimes is your own
voice is your is what you're hearing but
one other people when you actually hear
it out loud from other people it can
make you just change directions or go
yeah I need more of that I need less of
that but um that's not the answer I was
looking for no I write and I I I don't
need to hear other people say oh you
know I mean I normally don't but I have
done that no but no listen I but I know
other writers are like you most of them
are like I need to hear it I was like no
no you don't my writing is
all right studied English I don't need
people to hear and read myself it's
Flawless it's absolutely not the reason
it's because I feel like it's the table
reads never gonna be an accurate
representation of how this is going to
play out on its feet What actors are
going to bring to it you know how
they're going to interpret it it's never
going to be that and you know you can
kind of already hear like I know it
doesn't work on the page when I'm
reading it so I know it'll definitely
there's no one who can make this work
yeah you know that's just the way I feel
it I understand